so one of my favorite things about this
movie is I'm going to get to take my
four-year-old niece who is just
exploring movies like for the first time
where she's sitting through them
entirely now and it excites me because I
know there's going to come a time when
she looks back on one that she has seen
and say to herself like that was the
first time I was wholly consumed by
movie Magic so I want to know what that
movie is for you the very first time you
realize the power that big screen
storytelling could have I remember I
mean my the first memory that I have of
going to the theater was to go see
Pocahontas
and that was like
such a cool like just it's so immersive
when you're not just sitting in front of
like a 12-inch TV which is what we had
at home
um and just the sound and the colors and
the experience was it's like seared
seared in the old Dome I'm getting such
wholesome answers to that question and
I'm like Batman Returns watching Danny
DeVito like bite the head off of fish
that's my memory also very strong that's
really good sorry strawberry that's
cooler so this is your very first time
voicing an animated character I have
many questions about that first did you
seek out any advice for how to do that
and if so what is the best piece of
advice you were given I sought no advice
uh whatsoever which was my first big
mistake
um I I uh went in and in the first four
hour chunk that we did blew my voice out
entirely because I just I went for it
which is you know you gotta go for it
um but I didn't I I only use my voice to
talk on a daily basis and not to do like
big evil voices for the most part
um so I I did learn as we went along
that like I needed to do a bit of
warming up and I needed to take care of
myself a little bit more and not just go
in and scream my head off I understand
yeah so so warming up if you had to give
another piece of advice to another actor
who's about to do their first voice
acting gig what would it be I would say
do what I just did after the movie
wrapped which is
um sign up for voice lessons and even if
it's not to learn how to sing it's at
least to learn how to use your breath
properly and control your voice a little
bit more and
um yeah so I think drop into some
lessons if you can oh breath work is so
important is there anything surprising
you learn during those lessons that now
you're eager to apply to a future voice
acting gig okay so I just signed up for
the lessons I haven't I haven't taken
one yet signing up is signing up the
first step it's a very valuable step it
is important I but I'll let you know
okay okay I want to know we'll Circle
back okay I want to know a little bit
about working with uh Kirk and Farren
what is what did you appreciate about
the two of them the most as actors
directors especially you know coming to
understand what it means for a director
to direct an actor in a voice
performance versus one doing that on a
live action set
um I mean Kirk and farron were so much
fun and they were so collaborative so
you go in and you like the way we did it
was I would just read one line three
times and then we'd we'd open it up and
they'd throw out ideas and we'd chat
about it and they were just like
they were just it was clear how much fun
they were having with the project and
how passionate they were about it and
how there's still like a whole lot of
little kid infused in both of them so we
we did a lot of laughing and a lot of
like trying something out and often it
would sound ridiculous and sometimes it
would sound ridiculous in like the
perfect way so it was uh it was amazing
to work with can you give me an example
of something that you thought sounded
ridiculous you know maybe you took it to
an 11 or Beyond and you never thought in
a million years they'd use it and now
it's in the finished film
um
I think like one of my first really evil
laughs that I did you have a good evil
laugh I I know it came like
uncomfortably naturally
um but I did it and I kind of like
surprised myself and then I started to
laugh and they were like no no no like
can you do that again and I was like I
genuinely don't know
um but no it was it was so much fun spot
on I love it so going from voice acting
back to live action acting is there any
tool
toolkit so to speak that you think
actually might come in handy in live
action acting as well yeah yeah I I do
think the kind of like
lack of inhibition
the inhibition the lack of inhibition
just like getting into the booth
um and knowing that you're gonna look
ridiculous and knowing that you want to
try something and just doing it to see
how it works out I think it really I do
want to take that back to film to be
acting just
if you're gonna look dumb you're going
to look dumb but also if you're going to
figure something out sometimes you have
to look them or take a risk to do it and
so yeah I want to try to bring that back
with me demands fearlessness yeah I feel
like that's one of the best parts about
the experience so this will be a good
segue to this question this might get
awkward but I want to ask you about
efforts oh God I want to know what is
the effort that comes most naturally to
you that's the easiest to do but then on
the other hand I want to know what you
know an average everyday sound that's
like the most difficult to replicate in
one of your sessions
um the thing that comes the most easily
to me is laughing
and that's that's it's the efforts that
I we get to the effort page and I'm like
oh my God my God like you don't have a
trident in your hand and you're not
under the what so you have to like it's
the grunts and like the the kind of
guttural Screams that are not that don't
come as naturally to me which I guess is
a good thing
um and you're also kind of contained in
this really small Booth so even though
this the the action in the movie is like
literally throwing a trident you can't
do that so you just kind of have to like
tense your body as much as you can and
do small versions of like whatever the
the action is and it it looks ridiculous
I wish I had it I wish there was a
little video of everyone doing theirs
because there's a little bit of video
out there I have watched some of it
oh God it's not of me of everyone else
that's all I want to see it is all
delightful I will confirm you are all
doing exactly what you need to be doing
um a personal question inspired by Ruby
so this movie is all about Ruby finding
her power finding the value in her voice
I want to know the first acting project
that had that happen to you where you
kind of realized acting isn't just about
you know doing what I'm told and reading
the lines on the page but I have a voice
that I should share people should listen
it can influence projects that I work on
for the better wow uh hmm that is
something that I'm constantly working on
achieving I think but it was the role
that gave me the most confidence in
myself was definitely Alexis Rose and
shit's creek
um you know a bunch of seasons in and
and because there was huge imposter
syndrome going on
in the first bunch of seasons and
sometimes still but um but a bunch of
seasons in I was like I know I know what
I'm doing now and like it feels good and
I can strap on my stilettos and then
like walk onto set and feel like I know
what I'm doing you shouldn't have
imposter syndrome but when I think about
that the positive spin is that like you
have it because you've done something so
special that it's hard for you to
believe it
thank you that's right I'll try
sometimes thank you for your time today
congratulations on the phone thank you
so much